I I refuse to go complete in 2023 true I
will never say age incompletion yeah
don't be woke what that's woke I want to
create a whole new thing I did a
terrible thing recently what I was in
the car and we had to take a U-turn I
was kind of feeling the 90s slang Vibe
and so he said oh just go ahead and flip
a [__] do you guys remember that yeah I
still use it what does it even mean I
mean I know it's a U-turn yeah
but then I was with said you know you
can't say that anymore I was like it's
right it's 2023 so now I say go ahead
and flip a day laughs
yeah
that's true but you know what flip a
[__] is right it's when you're with a
[__] yeah yeah right and you're doing
missionary and you go flip over is that
true girl can you look it up
yeah that's true
that you would ask for her to flip over
and you and flip her over yourself
because you don't want to burn the
calories but here it is here's what it
means yeah yeah flipping a [__] is
making I don't know what's the
resulting in your passengers freaking
out or [__] their pants yeah I love
that freaking out is a hyperlink
[Laughter]
you turn it's like okay here's flipping
it flipping a [__] is making it illegal
what is that yeah I guess I'll click on
it later usually done in the middle of a
street or double line oftentimes you're
selling your passengers freaking out
what does that mean illegal is
misspelled too and look at the the the
demonstration of the it is if you flip
the [__] I almost [__] my pants yeah
I've never shipped my pants after a
u-turn
I have after your u-turns you go over
Islands oh that's true he does medium my
bad yeah my bad median hopping
it's just about can I ask another
question oh let's do the beginning I
didn't even introduce people forget
about the age in the room we got whites
right and we've got King white right
here TJ Miller King he's he's in he's so
good in the deadline a bunch of other
movies he's a great standout one of the
best thank you he's also my longtime
friend of mine he has a new special that
um that he's coming out
it's on YouTube right now right is great
yeah and now he has
um TPB and J the the the the the peanut
butter and the hot sauce yep yeah and
um give him a round of applause yeah
thank you guys thanks for having me and
I oh it's my favorite part I also made
fun of you that you didn't look as good
as Paul moveman you don't but in terms
of the comic in terms of a stand-up
you're pretty good looking I'm better
than Paul Newman in the stand-up World
stand up yes
oh that's well he was pretty good back
in the day he did some open mics did he
he did yeah yeah he used to kill the
dressing material yeah yeah and it's
always felt real with him it's always
organic right you know yeah and you get
a lot of ass after the [__] shows do
you think so when he flip the [__] or
just leave it
yeah because he's no he really was in
love and he stayed with the same woman
and he loved her and he would squeeze
her ass even in the older really yeah oh
I love horny Oldies But I Love oldies
you love horny old one more time I love
you he chose the horny oldies the only
the only
um I would love to be a really like just
vulgar horny grandma and terrorize my
grandkids with like sex stories and
things like that oh my God that's
interesting and then they'll be able to
do that yeah what if one of your
grandkids get on Woody
[Laughter]
wait does yours go all the way up like
that well to the sky yeah no not your
belly it's not a hovercraft or anything
no it just it's the worst thing it just
points out it goes into your eyes
yeah yeah can I ask you something
from